>> YOU'VE BEEN HEARING ALL WEEK
FROM THE WIRES THAT THE BORDER
PATROL, OFFICERS USED A WHIPPED
TO BEAT IMMIGRANTS AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER TRYING TO GET
REFUGEE STATUS.
EVERYTHING ABOUT THAT IS A
COMPLETE LIE.
A BUNCH OF HAD REFUGEE STATUS
AND OTHER COUNTRIES THEY DON'T
OFFER FREE HEALTHCARE, SO THEY
COME HERE.
BY THE WAY, THE BORDER PATROL
DOESN'T HAVE LIPS.
THEY RIDE HORSES, AND THE HORSE
HAVE RAINS.
SO THEY SHOT THIS PICTURE OF TH
WHIP, THEY CONFIRMED THAT THE
OFFICERS ARE USING RAINS AND
THEY'D WEREN'T WHIPPING ANYBODY.
THAT SHOULD BE THE END OF THE
STORY, BUT IT SUITS THE
POLITICAL PURPOSES WHICH IS
RUSHING AS MANY NEW PEOPLE INTO
THE COUNTRY AS POSSIBLE SO THEY
CAN WIN THE NEXT SEVERAL
ELECTION CYCLES.
THEY ARE CONTINUING TO LIBRARY
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
BANNED THE BORDER PATROL FROM
USING HORSES.
TODAY, JOE BIDEN, WHO HAS A
FETISH FOR GOING AFTER THE WEEK
WE NOTICE TO CRUSH THE HOURLY
WORKERS WHO WE'RE INVOLVED IN
THIS, THE BORDER PATROL OFFICERS
.
WATCH.
>> TO SEE PEOPLE TREATED LIKE
THEY DID, HORSES RUNNING OVER
AND PEOPLE BEING STRAPPED, IT'S
OUTRAGEOUS.
I PROMISE YOU THOSE PEOPLE WILL
PAY.
THEY'RE WILL BE AN INVESTIGATIO
UNDERWAY NOW, AND THERE WILL BE
CONSEQUENCES.
THEY'RE WILL BE CONSEQUENCES.
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT.
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE TALKING LIKE
THAT?
DOORS BORDER PATROL OFFICERS
DIDN'T BRING THEIR OWN HORSES T
BEAT IMMIGRANTS FOR FUN, THEY
WERE RIDING HORSES OWNED BY JOE
BIDEN'S GOVERNMENT.
THEY WERE DOING WHAT THEY WERE
TOLD TO DO WITCHES ENFORCE
FEDERAL LAW PASSED BY THE UNITE
STATES CONGRESS.
THEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITE
STATES, THESE ARE SOME OF THE
WEAKEST PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTRY,
THERE JUST BORDER PATROL AGENTS.
THEY HAVE NO POWER.
IMAGINE BEING MARRIED TO ONE OF
THESE GUYS ARE BEING THE CHILD
OF ONE OF THESE GUYS AND SEEING
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND WE'RE GOING TO CRUSH
THESE GUYS.
IS SIX.
SO THE DHHS SECRETARY IN KAMALA
HARRIS SAID THE OFFICERS USED
LIPS, THEY SAID THE WHIPS PROOF
THAT SYSTEMIC RACISM ISRAEL.
>> THIS INVESTIGATION INTO WHAT
OCCURRED HAS NOT YET CONCLUDED.
WE KNOW THAT THOSE IMAGES
PAINFULLY CONJURED UP THE WORST
ELEMENTS OF OUR NATION'S ONGOIN
BATTLE AGAINST SYSTEMIC RACISM.
>> THERE NEED TO BE CONSEQUENCE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
HUMAN BEING SHOULD NOT BE
TREATED THAT WAY.
AS WE ALL KNOW IT ALSO EVOKES
IMAGES OF SOME OF THE WORST
MOMENTS OF OUR HISTORY.
WHERE THAT KIND OF BEHAVIOR HAS
BEEN USED AGAINST THE INDIGENOU
PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTRY, HAS BEEN
USED AGAINST AFRICAN-AMERICANS
DURING TIMES OF SLAVERY.
>> SOMEONE WENT TOO HIGH SCHOOL
NOT EVEN FROM HERE, FROM CANADA.
HOW DID THE BEST COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD GET THE WORST PEOPLE IN
THE WORLD TO RUN IT?